meine schwestern liebe freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer runde mündigkeit gm
zusammen mit pixel wolf auf dem multi
core server halo besitzt auch beim corp
ein wenig rum da oben ja irgendwie
kriegt mich eigentlich runter wenn du
ins wasser fließt welches wasser fliege
jetzt mein kopf während du ihn bitten
künftig muss man ganz klar sagen und
zwar denkt ihr eventuell gerade hör ich
dachte kommt der kontakt hat ein urlaub
der sollte eigentlich am sonntag kommen
da ich kein internet dienst ein
gästehaus mittwoch komplett keine zeit
kam auf effekt und bla bla bla bla bla
jedenfalls wollte ich nur sagen dass
dann einfach der kontakt von walter ruf
league zu hin wann ich will
ich fahre jetzt kann ich dir unter ich
meine mutter alt war
naja ich kann hier und laufen ich bin
noch ein ziel ich wollte nur ganz kurz
sagen dass der kontakt dann quasi am
sonntag wirklich kommt weil es macht
keinen sinn wenn ich jetzt am donnerstag
noch heute den kontaktladen würde vom
letzten sonntag drei tage später wieder
video
deswegen habe ich den letzten kontakt
sonntag diese sonntag kommt dass wir
live video und übelkeit games besser
sagen ja sag uns war es heute es
erstmals zwei videos bringen
das wird auch das glaube ich länger zeit
das einzige mal beim also falls ich
nicht ist nicht das erste video heute
eigentlich gibt es best of five auch so
zum beispiel zu den games best of five
das heißt nicht dass wir fünf runden
spielen dass wir natürlich cool aber es
kann auch sein dass er hier 30 nimmt
dass der lokale erziehen
er ist dass ich ich werde nicht gewinnen
er wird gewinnen dass er die ersten drei
runden gewinnen
quasi beispielsweise und dann sind es
nur drei runden kann aber auch sein dass
er die ersten zwei runden werde ich die
nächsten zwei und wer dann wieder die
dritte die fünfte quasi und der drei
jahren doch wieder eine tolle statistik
bisher angegeben gewonnene 91 zu 34 du
hast doch bisher gegen jeden geworden
neben gespielt hast du ja genau und zu
haben mich gegen paar youtube gespielt
und habe ich gegen jeden 13 gewonnen aus
dem allgäu und gegen mich willst
wahrscheinlich auf den 30
ich mache jetzt mal ganz kurz den shader
aus ja ich noch aus so ich mache immer
so dass ich sage wir sehen uns dann
gleich in der nächsten runde und noch
einen kleinen pfad machst du das auch in
der nächsten runde der sat 1 die beste
werk ja kenne ich nicht
du musst schon mal gespielt also selber
gesagt ja aber ich habe nie der ton
gespielt ich habe immer nur die sachen
gespielt die diese anderem app dabei
diese mit diesen ganz vielen verzweigten
sachen mit dem holz war aus holz und
gold gold weil sie gar nicht nein ich
habe ständiger schwert ach so ja gut
leider verloren das macht ja nichts kann
ja mal passieren dass schon schwer
kranke schwester
ich sehe nichts du aktiv erleben hattest
du zweieinhalb ich jetzt wenn ihr wurden
gedruckt ich war so angespannt
ja aber ihr wisst ja ich bin will ich
kann das nicht nur glück zu diesen
zeiten gemacht mit der flash karte mit
dem enttäuschung endete vor glück dass
ich getroffen habe ich habe mich dann
aber auch als selbst auch getroffen
bereichen sind so komisch
ok solches wieder sagen sie in seiner
nächsten runde dann kommt doch hat es
klar wir sind jetzt sagen wir spielen
auf dem webportal die hat keine für uns
gespielt und mit welchen wert gesehen
habt super kann ich auch sagen dass
trattoria auf mexikanisch ok coole sache
schildkröte preis quasi schildkröte ja
ich hab nix ich finde keine kisten beim
sport auf jeden fall immer was aber ist
meine christian ich fand aber keine hier
habe ich gesagt dass eine kiste ist er
weg ist weil ich sehe auch ich war kein
kissen siehst du mich ich weiß gar nicht
wer der andere ist mit eurer ich habe
keinen abbau mehr kann man nicht
schweizer ist ein bogen aber keine
pfeile
minute her
ich habe deinen namen gesehen mein gott
walter ender verlief also wenn ich bin
direkt hinter dir gelandet direkt hinter
mir weißt du was ich habe mich hinter
der treppe versteckt ich hatte wohl
alter sich endlich hatte ich hatte eine
scheiß ich hatte eine ende flashen bogen
was zu essen auch ändert oder habe ich
deinen namen der ganzen gesehen dachte
ich okay verstecke mich ich sehe mich
ich habe das total vergessen dass man
sich damit ab allan poe raten kann ja
einfach meinen empfängerländer pellinger
dann warst du oh mein gott das ist ja
gar nicht gerechnet sagte trap und
überrascht dich von hinten wacklig
vollidiot
jetzt spielen wir ein lukas heimat weil
der zirkusdirektor aus der nach ansicht
nach seinem abi zu machen
auf jeden fall ich möchte löwe werden
ich muss ganz kurz gucken ich finde hier
wieder nix das sind alles besser das
sind alles um apps die ich zum ersten
mal sehe essen händler kiste übrigens
wenn du da auch diese tags drauf gehst
und ja ich weiß wo du gesprungen ist du
kennst ja alles so läuft denn hier
eigentlich hin ich habe ja auch nichts
wert sind aber ich kann damit der
nächste mal auch zwei reisen lasst uns
zusammen und auch welche das vergessen
wir uns darüber dass es ein kleines
podest vor dem riesenrad
ich bin auf dem riesenrad drauf ich
vollidiot er fährt jetzt erst mal einen
podestplatz um kleines busses für
sotschi sind zaun drum ist ja die kiste
habe ich schon aber nur zwei sind so
eine kacke
ich weiss ehrlich auf ich ein schwert
und bogen und fünf eile hat oder ob ich
nicht ich hab nichts du tötest michael
ob ich das sage um nicht zu verhelfen
aber ob ich gerade im zelt unterm
elefant bin ich finde gar nix ich hab
jetzt habe ich zwei rüstungsteile und
ist beides allerdings holz lederhose
was soll ich damit 2009 gegeben dann
kann ich dir endwert geben da wir
tauschen
ich habe nämlich zwei war wirklich wahr
tauschen was wirklich mal nicht stehe im
zirkuszelt direkt beim eingang
ja ich bin mittlerweile war da eben zu
diakonie in irgendeiner heute da ich vom
berghain gekrabbelt watterott ich glaub
ich weiß es ja kommen entgegen
aber dann bin ich direkt an ich habe
mich leider nein das mache ich habe hier
bin ich frei so dass wieder ein schwer
da jeweils die andere richtung laufen
hätten wir niemals wieder gesehen
jetzt habe ich aber nicht geben jetzt wo
bist du denn ich will kisten das jetzt
kommt
ein schwert wenig schwierig musst du
hast ein film und ein schwert unterhose
und bestimmt noch einbauen würde ich
jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen
nur weiß es nicht
doch die ganze zeit wieder hinterher
gelaufen geografisch am tag laufen haben
einen bogen und mein schwert entstand
okay okay auch gegen mich aber das erste
spiel hätte ich das gewordene das wäre
sogar selbst idee sei auch richtig knapp
das war richtig toll ist knapp aber
sagen alle wieder auf die b c a hat man
es aber du hast du geboren bist ich
kenne ich nie ich will ihnen zeigen
rechts verlässt ich meinte da ist ein
ende der kiste bevor jetzt alle schreibt
alles oh scheiße so verlief 30
das hat allerdings auch gemacht 30
verloren hatte habe ich ihn simon schon
gespielt und habe ich getan
er ist gar nicht viel also hast du schon
ich habe gleich darunter gesehen wurde
gegen simon gespielt hast und dass er
auch vorher gerade ja stimmt ja ich bin
bei 13 uhr habe ich ich sehe super tolle
blume hier
ich bin grad auf riesenrad mich zu wenn
ich mir da vergnügen oder auf der brise
rat an euro
seine süße wie behinderte warte mal ganz
kurz ein wie behindert ich bin ich werfe
länder perle und die prallte wo auf aber
ich werde nicht importiert
ja das ist des öfteren so das ist doch
mal da
ja ich bin jetzt beim sap ist er sich so
bin noch anhalten
hier ist auf seinem hof steht so im netz
von blöcken c geschrieben das denkmal
von crafter essen denkmal hatte wo ich
kann hier wieder seine enterprise hinter
mir liefen zwei wohnwagen bin ich auch
112 eile
häufig kommt dabei von xxs auf mich er
hat gedacht kommen wir können trotzdem
20 aufnehmen aber diese rolle dort
einfach schon sogar verdammt lange
deswegen habe ich auf die map gewählt
weil die ruhe nach hause kam hätte ich
denn die spd angst lee wo ich bin
diese rolle könnte zehn jahre dauern
er kann jetzt ist er nach zehn minuten
ist showdown
ja ich bin noch nie dagewesen
im showdown doch ich war schon beim
showdown echt wie sieht's aus weiß ich
hab ich heute ganz versteckt weil ich
keine items hatte hat mitgeschrieben und
dem schock habe ich dann die lava
gesprungen
doch der termin stand er schaut
aber du [ __ ] ich würde nicht tätig
denn apple verschwindet einfach wta
schlecht ach es war lief natürlich bord
ist die post der halle wahrscheinlich du
kleiner pisser heck des granate
eigentlich goliath - cover gibt es kurz
darauf gefasst machen einen fairen kampf
okay okay was mir weiß was hab ich da
überhaupt keine pilze im moment so
wartet muss ich ihnen kurz meine leben
ich hab dich irgendwie irgendwie habe
ich gerade drei herzen abgezogen
bekommen ja weil ich auch angeschlossen
wo bist du hast dich gesehen über sommer
einen spendablen tag genug ich gewählt
das ist aber kaka wenn du mir so was
gehen weil längst alle oder gibt sachen
du verlierst trotzdem erwarte meine
leben sind sofort wieder voll moment
einen moment einen moment ein mensch in
die ferien noch ein herz noch ein halbes
herz und der kampf beginnt a321 ich sehe
dich nicht du bist bist du
ender perle 30 schilder ich lauf
rückwärts ich sehe da kommt einer zu mir
hin und wieder mal nichts böses im
schilde einfach nur so denkt so ist er
sagte komm fairer kampf in dem trotzdem
länder perle
ich dachte wieder aufeinander zu und
kämpfen und bettelten pixel wolf 3 0
noch eine kleine runde machen auf der
kleinsten ab da fühlt man sich sofort
simons da wir jetzt sind wenn der
extrarunde jetzt ist es eigentlich
relativ egal wie es ausgeht ist ein
verlorener nie die zählt drei punkte
haben wir beschlossen sei dann wäre dann
könnte ich trotzdem höchstens auf und
entschieden rauskommen wichtig weil er
trotzdem ich habe jetzt von pfeile durch
bin inmitten der map du siehst mich
wahrscheinlich schon
hier gibt es auch nur mitten in dem ihm
zu klein ist
40 verlor super hatte ja die map ich
kannte aber keine von max ich kenne nur
eine merklich dauerhaft spiele das ist
so eine holz map mit zehn jahren überall
und so richtig bewusst nur wo es nur
drei blöcke jahre wiener stil jedenfalls
sollte wenn es euch trotzdem gefallen
hat und eventuell mehr syndicate games
bald vielleicht gegen jemanden gegen die
ich auch gewinnen weil meine statistik
ist zeigt zu euch mal an den kommissar
der nächste und ich bin nicht so blöd
liebesspiel
ich habe 90 kills fast bei den 100 naja
gut freunde wird euch gefallen hat dann
besten bewertung da und schreibe es in
die kommentare und coop bei pixel wolf
vorbei
spontan bei wenn ihr sehen wollt ihr
bisschen familie konnte doch bei mir
sehen wie ich gestorben bin irgendwann
anders wieder konter kommt am sonntag